cómo llegar de un lugar a otro hay
muchas maneras de hacerlo pero algunas
nos llevan más tiempo que otras y a
veces podemos recorrer distancias más
largas de lo necesario
para ayudarnos a elegir la mejor ruta
podemos utilizar un mapa pero primero
hay que ubicar nuestro punto de partida
los nombres de las calles y los lugares
de interés observa el siguiente mapa
qué elementos tiene en azul podemos ver
los símbolos que hacen referencia a
lugares establecidos como un hospital un
restaurante un estacionamiento y una
gasolinería las avenidas están marcadas
en color amarillo las calles en blanco y
ambas tienen flechas que indican el
sentido en el que van en este mapa
tenemos calles y avenidas que tienen el
mismo nombre así que fíjate bien puede
pasar que encuentres calles y avenidas
que se llamen igual por eso es
importante que sepas diferenciarlas pero
como las avenidas suelen ser vías
principales por lo general tienen mayor
circulación de automóviles y pueden ser
más anchas por el contrario las calles
tienen menor circulación de autos y son
un poco más angostas sin embargo esto no
es una regla depende de cada ciudad o
país pero estos tips te pueden ayudar a
identificarlas te invito a que
investigues cómo son en dónde vives
supongamos que vamos en bicicleta por la
calle 7 y un señor que viene manejando
por calle 2 detiene su automóvil justo
esquina para preguntarnos cómo llegar a
la gasolinería qué indicaciones le
darías yo le diría que diera vuelta a la
izquierda siguiera derecho tres calles
hasta la avenida 4 acá y diera vuelta a
la derecha y que avanzara dos cuadras
como puedes darte cuenta es muy
importante ubicar las calles y saber dar
indicaciones me ayudas a encontrar el
estacionamiento para poder guardar
nuestras bicis recuerda que estamos
ubicados en calle 2 esquina con calle 7
qué ruta nos conviene más para no dar
tanta vuelta ojo respetemos los sentidos
viales de las calles como ciclistas
también tenemos que hacerlo podemos
seguir derecho sobre calle 7 como la
avenida 4 es de doble sentido damos
vuelta a la izquierda vuelta a la
derecha en la calle 13 y en la calle 10
dar vuelta otra vez a la derecha
perfecto encontramos el estacionamiento
en la esquina de calle 9 y 10 creo que
es la mejor ruta
como ya guardamos la bici en el
estacionamiento queremos pasar por un
helado para eso solo debemos caminar por
la calle 9 y dar vuelta a la derecha en
calle 12 pero qué creés nos acaba de
hablar un amigo para decir que viene en
camino por nosotros va saliendo de la
escuela y lo único que nos pide es que
le demos la dirección que le dirías la
heladería se ubica sobre calle 12
esquina con calle 5 y le podemos dar un
dato más las calles cercanas son calle
10 y calle 7 perfecto dos minutos más
tarde nuestro amigo habla de nuevo para
comentarnos que se perdió porque puso el
mapa al revés
uff cuidado que esto no te pase a ti es
muy importante identificar cuál es tu
derecha y cuál es tu izquierda en el
mapa
una forma sencilla de ubicarte es viendo
lo que hay alrededor como colocaría el
mapa hacia la derecha tienes calle 4 de
frente calle 13 y a la izquierda avenida
4 fácil lo que tienes que hacer es girar
el mapa para poder ver en la parte de
arriba lo que tú ves de frente y
mientras vas avanzando irlo girando
según vayas cambiando de ruta una vez
que nuestro amigo reviso el mapa de
acuerdo a su orientación pudo encontrar
la heladería sin ningún problema en este
caso fue sencillo porque únicamente
tenemos calles avenidas y algunos
símbolos pero existen otros mapas con
más información que debes saber
interpretar
todos los mapas tienen un recuadro de
especificaciones que nos indican qué
representa cada color cada tipo de línea
y cada símbolo es importante que ubicas
algunos en caso de que lo requieran
tal vez necesitas hacer una llamada
telefónica ubicar la estación de policía
más cercana o tomar algún medio de
transporte como el taxi o un autobús